Thật tối như bảo tạng mình
Bây giờ trước tốt soát cho các bạn ạ
Xin nhận
Các bạn cho nó làm đúng cũng
Được rồi
Mình
Cái mù là việc phải bọn nhóc
Nó nhau tăng nữa
Cái thiệt mà, cho ý biết
Tụi, cho làm đúng không phải chỉ xem đúng sao?
Vì dợi đứng nhìn
Ờ thật một chăm mình trong nhà thực kai
Như là sản thạo trên nâng là này,
với trình đúng vậy
hay là ảo cá làm rất là suốt mắc hồ nữa
bạn đến đây sẽ không chỉ để xong mịch sử
mà bạn đến
còn để thực tay làm ra một sần của nó nữa
các bạn đến đây là nó và
và hợp lại những cái hình lịch sử của mình
và họ có thể ngớt mình
vài nó được trải hiện về các bạn ngay thu công
thực thành để mình hiểu hơn
Ừ
bạn học xanh chính
quốc so cuộc với học xanh khâu hạ
hãy chỉ dành cho người lớn
cuộc về mọi lưu tội như bạn nói
nhưng học xanh tạo học này đến với lớn
để hụi khách thành ra được
làm một trong những thương trình
được yêu thích nhất
và người cứ là cái em
của học của chơi của sản thẩm mắc hình nhé
Ở đây thì thay vì là các bạn
đến đến với công việc
là phương gên của chơi mà để làm như cái
Ừ, sốt trải hiện về các bạn
và để đến mà các bạn hậu được
những cái sẻ khó được
thì cũng sốt đấy
thay vì học me sửa trong sách với câu là
vũm bất chàng rồi
tiếng với cái kia thì bạn phải tự tay để nặng
mà mình phải là một cái niếp
phải là một cái mắt thì tốt
thì tự tốt nó sẽ
tự tự tự nó ngắm thẳng và đau ở các bạn
tự tự tự tự tự tự lần
công đi mình muốn tổ chức tình như đing
quốc chau này có nhận khâu
nhận luôn, tổ luôn
nhận này, vô xong có thể tổ chức thương nhỏ này
ra định chưa học công tình như đều được
mỗi người ra về cái mức sản thẩm tự
thay và tổ chuyện về làm về chuyện tổng hà lỗi
ý nghĩa hơn ăn kìa rất là nhiều
hình là hãy chứ
vô xong có lịch của đến không hạy là phải sợ
có gấp dục
bình thì và gạchhoi gâu
trong nỏ mạng
, itchy ngày mà thực sự mà phát thăm về về về về về về về về về về
vô
nhận thấy chả dạy hei mà đã gì các bạn
có thể tự lễ bảo kàng
ah, nó một lần trong viết nhà
bây giờ có bạn y sao
bạc một thử vô xong3000
có mẹn bưới
và có lời trụ về bên lịch của Good Shust
à
Trời ơi